Well, listen, I'm really thrilled to be here with you two today. I didn't think I was going to make it. What happened? JB was, he was close. He almost didn't make it through the weekend. And then the doctor, they decided to revive him with two almonds. Brought him back to life. And they come in and they go clear, pop, pop.
I was a little lightheaded yesterday, but two nuts in my mouth really, they fix a lot. Brought you to life. I know how you feel. Welcome to Smart Life. Smart. Lightest. Smart.
Lightest. Smart. Smart. Smart. Lightest. Smart. Smart. Lightest. Smart. Smart. Hey JB, JB before Rob, little Rob show yourself again real quick. Just let's see Arm Yarv. And he said JB Rob says, Toshan I've got your favorite sports team on my hands.
It says spaghetti. That's very good. That's fun. Isn't that fun? It's fun. It's good clean fun. It is good clean fun. So good morning. Good morning, Jason. First things first. Please, you know I'm obsessed with medical stories.
Please tell me what happened to you three, four days ago. Oh. Well, I'm obsessed with medical stories, please tell me what happened to you three, four days ago. Oh, well, I'm still in it, unfortunately. You still feel like crap? Well, it's just the things, things are loose, okay? Oh, Jesus. And, you know, I think what it is, God bless my wife, she is more on top of the health stuff than you are even,
which I guess is not that high of a bar to leap over considering you mainline meatloaf and everything. But she gave me this, some sort of supplement for longevity, right? It's like a peptide or something or other. New? Huh? New or been taking it?
No, no, no, yeah, just a couple of weeks ago. And then she had me take even a little bit more last weekend and that's what did it. I'm pretty sure that's it. For sure, well, first of all, we ruled out immediately food poisoning. Because it would have had to have been bad lettuce. Well, because you would have had to eat.
Eat, eat. So that's off the table. I know. I mean, it was like the flu, the flu, like if you'd had like a stomach bug, it would have moved through you by now. No, it's still, yeah, I'm fatigued and I can't eat. And like, and look how puffy my eyes are too. It's like, whatever this thing is, like I gotta stop it,, I'm fatigued and I can't eat. And look how puffy my eyes are too.
It's like, whatever this thing is, I gotta stop it, which I'm doing. Yeah, you're okay, very good. It'd be great if the longevity thing killed you. I mean, I just. She did say she got a deal on it. But. Well, I'm glad you're feeling better than you were before.
Yes, oh yeah, yeah, I had to cancel a day of work. I haven't done that for a long time. But you guys are very, very sweet. You're just, you know, you guys are a couple of the good ones. I don't care what they say. And you're incredible at reading ads. Did you guys just win an award for your ad reading?
Did you guys? I think we all did. Why? Well wait, am I a part of it? Yeah. You wanna get to our host? Yeah. Okay, great.
And so, you know, this guy is a media titan. He's incredibly smart, incredibly funny. He is responsible for one of my favorite shows. I was very sort of, not nervous, but this show has gone through a couple of hosts and I was hoping that it would land on somebody even better and they have. And he's got multiple irons on the fire.
This guy's just, he's cycle high, I think is what they say. He's doing tons of stuff and it's all fantastic. I'm gonna let him tell you about it, but I'm very, very excited he said yes to doing this today. Any guesses? I can't, I have no idea. Me, Chris, Jason, Joseph doing this today. Any guesses? I can't, I have no idea. Me, me, me.
Chris, he's, he's, he's, he's, he's, he's, he's, he started in standup. An additional hint. He hosted a political comedy show on Comedy Central. First name starts with T. Last name starts with N. Trevor Noah. Everybody, it's Trevor Noah. It's Trevor Noah. It's. Everybody, it's Trevor Noah.
It's Trevor Noah. It's Trevor Noah. It's Trevor Noah. I mean. What's going on everybody? Hey. Hi everybody. From the original, from the original sort of lead in,
I thought, or set up, I thought it was like, this is like a newscaster. We got like Walter Cronkite coming in. I was confused for a moment. I genuinely thought it was someone else. Yeah, usually I write these things, but this fricking job I've got in New York, it's really cutting into my prep time. So this interview is going to be even worse than the normal ones.
Yeah, I was thrown. But then you said the name, then I was like, okay, we're good. You were like, oh, it's me. It's still me. I mean, let's start right there. I mean, did you feel the pressure I felt when you were going in there to take over this incredible show? Yeah. I mean, so here's the thing.
When I was going in to take over The Daily Show, I don't think I felt the, I don't think I felt the amount of pressure that I should have felt. Because I didn't grow up with The Daily Show, and I met John Stewart just as a stand-up comedian meeting another stand-up comedian. And I mean, we still talk about that now. Now that John has gone back to hosting the show,
we'll still share the stories of how ironically the other day we were on the phone. And I was saying to him, it's funny that we've gone full circle. When we first spoke, it was on the phone and I was traveling through like Dubai and England doing comedy shows. And then now when we spoke and he's host again, I'm traveling and I was literally in Dubai calling him, having another conversation. It's literally gone full circle. But I wasn't nervous.
And then I think after the first few episodes, then the nerves kicked in, which is strange. It's literally gone in a circle. But I wasn't nervous. And then I think after the first few episodes, then the nerves kicked in, which is strange. Normally it's the other way around. Because now you've got a better idea for what it is than you did then. Oh yeah, definitely. And a better idea of how people reacted to it. I think that was the biggest thing.
Because it's so important. It's like this great... It's sort of this Trojan horse that's on a network. It's helping all the medicine go down a little bit easier. The medicine that's so vital for all of us to be taking in. Definitely. What joke really kills in Dubai? Huh, that's an interesting one.
And then tell us what joke you can't tell in Dubai. So what joke really kills in Dubai. So whenever I travel for my shows, it makes it a lot harder, but what I love to do is find comedy that I could only do in that region. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So I always try to find something, whether it's an observation, whether it's an experience, but just something that you could only say in Dubai
and then some local not living there would go, wait, what does that mean? So I'll try to tell a few jokes that have like an Arabic punchline or, you know. I'll play with something in that world. I mean, isn't Dubai like that super rich, like aren't they incredibly, isn't Dubai like that super rich, like, aren't they incredibly... Isn't everybody incredibly wealthy?
Let's go for the definition of it. Go ahead, Sean. We're gonna fight it again. Isn't Dubai that kind of wealthy place? Try to be less articulate. Go ahead. Have you ever been outside the United States? Oh, of course. I know Dubai. Sure, of course. What kind of jokes do you tell about...
Isn't like every single human being there super wealthy? I know Dubai, I was just wondering like, what kind of jokes do you tell about, isn't like every single human being there super wealthy? Yeah, well I mean the Emiratis are pretty wealthy, but then most of the audiences is expats. I think it's like 90%, yeah, 90%. It's one of the most diverse audiences you'll perform for. Oh, that's so great, I love that. Did you ever get up there when you were coming up
in South Africa, did you ever get up there when you were coming up in South Africa? Did you ever get up there and were any of your dates up in that area? Oh yeah. Yeah. Like when I had to take over the Daily Show, I had to let go of a bunch of dates that were happening around the world. So I just got a foothold into touring all over the, you know, all over the planets. I've had to do that a lot, let go of a lot of dates all over the, you know, all over the planets. I've had to do that a lot, like go over a lot of dates
all over the globe. Yeah, I know. Because I'm just, meh, because I just didn't want to, because I didn't want to seem like. I want to know, you know, when you first came on the scene. Why is the sky blue? Sorry, was that not it? Yeah, that's not it.
That's because it's a reflection of the. Ocean. Ocean, yeah. So, Trevor, when you first came on The Daily Show, that was my first discovery of you. I was like, oh, what a glorious, wonderful discovery of this man. But before that, bad on me, I didn't quite know.
So like where you came from or what you're. No, should you know, yeah. So what was life before that and what led you to getting that job? It's funny, you know, I'm never offended by that and I don't know why. Some people apologize for that. Again, I find it's quite common for people to say that in America. They'll say, I'm sorry, I didn't know you.
Strange, strange thing here. Because it's such a massive platform. We feel badly that we didn't follow your career before you got the big surely you don't know somebody before you know them That's how knowing people works. I'm always I'm writing that down But now you can't walk down the street, I'm sure Knowing someone were you think I understand he apologized to physics before he learned it? Yeah, right.
But you were crushing it in stand-up such that you met with John? Yes. Yeah, so it was really random. I was... So I started comedy in South Africa, performed there my whole life. I was lucky enough that we... What part of South Africa were you... So I was born in Johannesburg, raised in Soweto and Johannesburg, and then that's where I did most of my comedy.
We didn't have a comedy club, so just to give you a bit of a backstory, I'm assuming you know, but if you don't, so during apartheid free speech was illegal in South Africa, right? And so you weren't allowed to gather, you know, a group of black people weren't allowed to be in one space, and there were all these laws. So stand-up comedy, obviously, you know, is one of the first things that's outlawed in any place that restricts speech.
Wow. So we didn't even have comedy clubs, we didn't have anything. And then once democracy started in 1994, all of a sudden there was just like a boon of new, a boon of people being like, can we sit together? Can we laugh together? God, that must have been exciting. And comedy blew up in the most informal places.
Comedy was this huge explosion. And you were how old at that time? No, so I only got into comedy. in 94. I'm six years old. I only got into comedy when I was 20 I want to say 21 Okay, and it was it was still nude like that You couldn't make a living from comedy which I which I loved about it It really was something that everyone was doing It wasn't like in the US where people would do comedy so they could get a sitcom, so they could become a movie star.
So no, there it was, you do comedy because you like comedy. There is no part. And also escape the horror of their upbringing. Oh yeah, well I think that's what all comedy is even in the US to be honest with you. Yeah. I think everyone's doing comedy to escape their horrible upbringing.
But you actually wrote a book about it too, right? Yeah, yeah I did. Which became a, what did it sell, like three million copies? I don't know, I don't like numbers to be honest with you. It did very well. No, no, no, I mean this honestly, you know why. I don't like numbers when they're good and I don't like them when they're bad.
Right, you and me both. Why don't you like them when they're good? Because if you live by the good numbers then you must die by the bad numbers. Absolutely. I think if you're creating, you should just create and then act. I'm so with you then, you're not at the effect of outside circumstances. So Trevor, so walk me through, so you come up in a place that is almost,
that has just a very new comedy scene, if you will. Yeah. And now you go, you start touring, you do lots of great stuff, then you take over The Daily Show and you just absolutely explode into the comedy world. When you go back to South Africa, are you, is it safe to say that you're kind of like
the first big South African comedy star? Oh yeah. Is there a lot of pressure associated with that? You know what? Not pressure. Not pressure. We... It's so much fun, man. It's hard to explain. So the difference between the two places, I find, in America, fame is almost like royalty. Right. That's why people apologize if they may be unaware
if you had some beforehand. Yes. I was not aware that you were off your car. I apologize. My liege. Silence, Dave! In South Africa, it's just like people know you. Everyone just treats you like you're part of a big family. That's how it feels. And was it equally welcoming when you came back and you were now famous? Or were they like, oh, were they sort of circumspect and like, let's see if he changed?
I was pretty well known before I left South Africa. So it was just like, oh, congratulations, you've gone and put us on the world stage doing something. That's great. Wow. So tell me about, I imagine when you were doing a bunch of touring, you got used to life on the road and all the bumps and bruises that go along with it. And then you got this incredibly prestigious job and I'm sure we're making a whole hell of a lot more money
than you were before and getting used to thread count, nice candles and soaps and the lot. Thread count. How has it changed you and made you more soft now and it's tougher going back out on the road? I'm sure, you know, I know you're playing arenas and stadiums and stuff, but Ken, is the old Trevor still alive?
It's funny, my life went the other way around. When I first started The Daily Show, I was actually earning less than I was doing stand-up around the world. I was working hard and I was doing pretty well. So it was really taking the job because of the challenge and the opportunity. As for the thread count, I think my life became a little bit worse because now I was in New York in the winters, walking down the street in like a mini blizzard,
walking down like 11th Avenue. I don't know if you've been to the Daily Show studios in New York, it is one of the worst parts of New York. Like in one of the worst parts ever. And it's not like worst part just to clarify for the listener, in that it's dangerous, it's just more that it's shitty. It's really shitty. Dangerous would be better because then it means
people are there to do something to you. Yes, exactly. It's like a barren wasteland of nothingness. It is such a fucking nothing area. Yeah, it's just a pocket of nothing. So tell us about the meeting with John and how that whole sort of idea sparked in John and how he approached you
and what that conversation was like. So I got a call. I was, you know, it's one of those moments where you remember exactly what was happening, but not because of how momentous it was in that moment, rather because of how random the thing is that I was doing. I was in London. I was doing my first tour of the UK.
And on this particular day, I was standing in Harrods, the mega department store that sells everything. And when I say everything, I mean everything. You all probably know it. And I couldn't afford anything in Harrods. Maybe like, you know, maybe some of the croissants, I don't know. And I was standing in front of an underwater moped. Like a, you know, like an underwater scooter thing, like you ride it like a motorbike but underwater.
I have one. Yeah, don't bore Will, he's got one for him and all four boys. Wait, an underwater moped, okay. Yeah, yeah, like you see, this is what my brain was doing. At that exact moment, my brain was doing the same thing. I was just standing there staring at it going What is this? Why is this and why don't I try and get one and hold your breath while you ride the bike? No, it has a little bubble, you know like those old those old
Sky, what do you call it? Like the diving before they had the tanks? Bubble over your belt. It has that It's a bubble over your head. And then my phone rang, some long number, I had no clue what, and I answered the phone, because I don't owe anybody money. And the voice on the other end was like, hey, is this Trevor? And I was like, yeah, and he's like, hey, this is John Stewart. I was like, okay. And he's like, yeah, not really, maybe, I don't know. And he's like, well, I work on a show called The Daily Show. And I was like, oh, I think I've heard of that.
Because I had seen it on CNN International, because we didn't have it on other channels in the world. And I was like, oh, yeah, I've heard of it. And he's like, oh, as you should have, young man. He's very funny, you know John. Yeah, I love John. Yeah, and then he invited me, you know, he's just like, come and hang out, I think you're funny,
and I like the way you see the world. Come and hang out with me when you get a chance. And so at first I said no. I was like, I've got the tour. And he's like, are you saying no? What did he say? He said, are you saying no to the trappings of American fame and popularity? Who are you, young man?
I said, no, I've got a tour. I'll see you when I see you. And he said, well, if you're in New York, look me up. And I said, definitely. Thanks for the call. It's nice to hear from you. And then I went to New York, I think six months or eight months later, he called me again. He's like, I hear you're in town, but you didn't look me up. And I was like, oh, Jesus, this guy's relentless.
So you hadn't told your agent about this phone call, who would have probably... No, I think they gave him my number because they were like, it's John Stewart. What if you had hung up the phone with John Stewart and then the woman at the desk at Herod said, sir, your underwater moped has been paid for by Mr. Stewart. You're like, fuck, I gotta go do this. This guy's a baller.
This guy, yeah, I gotta go. I mean, then you say yes immediately, right? Yeah, of course. Yeah, then it's like a full on. So he tracks you down eight months later in New York. Yeah, and then. He says, come have coffee. He said, come to the show and hang out.
Just hang out, and that's all I did. I went there, we hung out. I remember them talking about like John Boehner or something and then I was like, what is this world? What is going on here? So you had no idea about the political landscape in America? I knew the larger, the larger, you know, in the rest of the world, we keep up with American politics, you know, on a big scale.
But the finer minutiae, you know, filibustering and, you know, no. Sorry to interrupt again, but the John Boehner story, wasn't about him crying in some kind of like hung over with like red wine on his teeth. Yeah, I think it was then. It was around that point. Yeah, okay. So you didn't really learn all the specific small-time cretins that populate the house? No, no, no. I did not. Gotcha.
We'll be right back. Thanks to Viori for supporting the show. Are you tired of uncomfortable workout clothes? Look no further than Viori. Everything is designed to work out in but doesn't look or feel like it. Their clothes are so comfortable you'll want to wear them all the time. They've taken the activewear world by storm with their high quality and stylish designs. Whether you're hitting the gym, going for a run, or just running errands, they have the perfect outfit for you. Whether you're hitting the gym, going for a run, or just running errands,
they have the perfect outfit for you. For me, I've recently discovered, and now enjoy tremendously, the Sunday Element hoodie. Why? Because in LA, it's kind of hot during the day, but it gets really cold at night. So to wear a hoodie all the time, it's like it takes care of all the weather problems
here in LA. Because it's thin enough to wear during the day, and thick enough to keep you warm at night. I just love it. Viori is an investment in your happiness and they're hooking up smartless listeners with 20% off your first purchase at Viori.com slash smartless. That's V-U-O-R-I dot com slash smartless. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any U.S. orders over $75 and free returns. Go to Viori.com slash smartless and discover
the versatility of Viori clothing. Go to Viori.com slash smartless and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. We get support from Helix. We've talked a lot about Helix and for good reason. I have the dusk lux and I sleep like a baby. Helix knows there's no better way to test out a new mattress than by sleeping on it in your own home. That's why they offer a hundred night trial and a 10 to 15 year warranty. So how will you know which Helix mattress works best for you and your body? Well, their team created a Helix sleep quiz to help you find your perfect mattress in under two minutes. And your mattress is shipped straight to your door free of charge. I took the quiz and like
I said, I got matched with the Dusk Lux because I wanted that medium feel like just like Goldilux which just perfect because I'm on my side a lot and I'm but I also kind of move around But it's perfect for me. It's like they read my mind Helix is offering 30% of all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listeners go to helixsleep.com Smartless that's helixsleep.com Smartless this is their best offer yet and it won't last long with helix better sleep starts now won't last long with Helix, better sleep starts now. Smart List is brought to you in part by Audible. Audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment
in one app. You'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover. They offer an incredible selection of audio books across every genre, from bestsellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs, mysteries and thrillers, motivation, wellness, business, and more. Audible is your destination for thrilling audio entertainment
with highly anticipated new releases and next listen recommendations for every type of thriller listener. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. For me, I just recently watched The Shining, a movie that I've always loved
that was actually a book first. And I wanted to know how the book was different from the movie, if at all. So I started listening to The Shining. It's narrated by Campbell Scott and it's really really good and it kind of augments what's already great in the movie. So it's really really cool to listen to something of a movie that I already love. It's really really interesting. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500
to try Audible free for 30 days. Audible.com slash smartless. All right, back to the show. What year did you come to the US? I think this was 2015. So 2015 and then you're doing a comedy tour, John Stewart's hassling you, and at the time, what kind of comedy stuff were you into? So you know, this is actually interesting. I remember somebody asked me, they said to me,
when The Daily Show happened, they said, so are you going to, they said, are you a political comedian? You know, the Daily Show is very political. And I said, oh no, no, no, I'm not. I genuinely was like, I'm not a political comedian. I don't even, I don't think of myself that way. When I spent a little time in the US, I came to realize that what I thought of as non-political humor would be considered ultra-political humor in America.
Right. Because here the average person doesn't... I think it's changed since Trump, but back when I first got to the US, most people didn't engage in politics. People would literally say, I don't follow politics, I don't get involved, I don't follow politics.
Right. Whereas in South Africa, what we consider a basic level of commenting or being involved in the system, we don't think that's political. For us, political is marching in the streets, freeing people from prison, like protesting the system. That's being political. Because in most parts of the world, just being engaged is sort of your civic duty. That's the baseline.
Right, no matter where you're in South Africa or Dubai, where isn't it full of rich people or something? Anyway. Right, that's the spot. I have to. But I'm so fascinated that John and the rest of the brain trust over there thought that you would be a great choice
to take over a show that is a mix between comedy and politics politics so it necessitates a full understanding of the comedy world, a full understanding of the political world such that you can blend the two together, find the nuance, find the irony, and wrap it all up in a bunch of jokes for half an hour or more.
Talk to me about how, did they explain to you what their expectations were and how you needn't worry about not even being from here and haven't lived here in a long time? And how did that go? Well, initially, it was, I always describe the story as feeling a lot like Charlie and the Chocolate Factory. In that I popped in, I had a great time with John,
and I said to him, I was like, I like what you guys are doing, I guess, but this is not for me. And then we laughed about, we would just, man, because John and I, we get along. You know, there's comedians where you click with them, and your rhythm and your vibe is almost completely simpatico, you're just in it. I'd like to find the person that doesn't get along
with Jon Stewart though. I mean he's like an all time great guy. But the comedy is like, you know when it comes to comedy, I find there's a, it's like music. All musicians can play together but some musicians can create magic together and when you find comedians that you share that with, it's pretty special. Yeah, well there's beats and rhythm, go ahead. can create magic together and when you find comedians that you share that with, it's pretty special.
Yeah, well there's beats and rhythm. Go ahead. As you can see, I'm still looking. We've got them on a separate volume control. I'm still on server. Don't worry. Sean, real quick, Sean, Sean, real quick. Any follow-up questions about the chocolate factory?
It's not a real place, but if you have anything that you'd like to... Isn't that full of people who like chocolate? I have a thousand questions about the chocolate factory. Oh my God. Last night I made an ice cream sundae and I didn't have any whipped cream, so I made whipped cream. Oh my God, are you writing a screenplay about it now? Hey, Trevor, would you venture to say that actually
coming here, kind of a follow up to what Jay was saying, that being an outsider gave you your perspective almost a bit of an advantage, I would suggest, because you don't have American politics or what we've sort of takes for granted as to how the system works and what the dynamics are between the different, the left and the right if you will, just to make it as basic as possible, because you come in with a different perspective.
And you just take it as face value, like oh this is a clown show, as opposed to being somewhat padded with understanding the whole political system and that it's kind of a joke anyway. So I think it was a massive disadvantage and an advantage. The disadvantage is people don't like anyone who doesn't look like them or sound like them coming to tell them anything about them.
So I spent weeks getting random death threats and letters. People hated how I said controversy. And then it was, you know... The word controversy? Yeah, controversy. But did you really get death threats, Trevor? Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. That's, I mean... That's quite... It's like, it's powerful, the course I've learned.
As soon as you comment on American politics in a public forum, that's pretty much what happens to you. So that was a disadvantage. Here's something I don't get about the whole phoning in or emailing in a threat. A bomb threat or a death threat. Like, aren't those the exact kind of threats you don't need to really worry about because who the hell would warn you before they play? Like, I don't... I'm certainly not belittling it whatsoever,
but I'm always like, I can't believe that someone will clear out an entire office building if they get a bomb threat. It's like, well, if they wanna put a bomb in there, they're probably just gonna do it and not tell you about it. So they're- The irony that you look so much like Ted Kaczynski right now while you're saying this is fucking killing me.
I know. No, I just, you know, I get that they've got to empty the building for insurance reasons, because there's going to be a record that they received the threat, but. So to that, did you ever feel genuinely threatened in a way that was not just a sort of a random kind of. I'm sure, of course. I don't know, I mean it's...
Scary. Yeah, there's a latent level of anxiety that comes with anybody threatening you. And again, I need to state, I don't think it's that uncommon. I'm pretty certain all the other late night hosts have gotten death threats. It's just, it varies varying degrees. Kimmel gets one a day, I think. I've threatened Kimmel twice this week already myself. On the beginning of Will and Grace,
we used to get death threats all the time. Ah, there you see. In 1998. So back then, but was that like people sending- Just for shitty jokes or? Yeah. Yeah. People. You know, we have fun, Trevor. We do.
We just have fun. No, that was because, wait, what was the question? What were the threats about it? Will and Grace. Oh no, yeah, they were written on, yeah, people took the time to sit down. There's one, this one real, this wasn't a death threat, one of the greatest letters we ever got was, I'm not sure what you're talking about. I'm just reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments.
I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments.
I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. But this one woman wrote in and she said, you know, we're all going to hell. You should be ashamed for putting this on television. You are all horrible people.
But I love the show, I just don't know what, I just don't like what it's about. Oh wow. And could you send me an A510? Yeah. Can I get some tickets for the April 12th show? That's the craziest thing. That's so fucking crazy.
I guess it stands to reason that you would get threats. I mean, do you get threats immediately upon doing it? I guess I'm sure that a lot of the threats were, we can all take our pick what they could be about. You're a lefty, right? You're a liberal or? Well, and also you were in, I mean, 2015, I mean, the kerosene had been put on the dumpster
and it was about to burst in flames. That's exactly it. 12 months later. It was the beginning of Donald Trump and everything that America now lives in as a normal state. Yeah. So that was the majority of your material and so they're going after the person that's in there.
I mean, think about that. So you're right. You started, you came to America, as Jason's right at the beginning of the, they were just putting the kerosene, the kindling on the dumpster fire that we all now live in. That's been your experience of America. Let me just say, we've had some good times here, dude. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
I'm now amended with it. If I get the time machine, what I'm doing is I'm grabbing Trevor and I'm taking him back to like the mid 90s into the mid 2000s. Because we had a lot of fun. It looked like a lot of fun. It really was. I don't want you to get the wrong impression. Happy days are here again soon, I promise.
It's also wild that people, instead of just not watching you, or listening to this or watching that or whatever, they take the time to watch it and then comment on it. Just turn the channel. Instead of just turn the channel, yeah. Yeah, but you know, at the time, it was so hard launching The Daily Show
that I actually preferred having those people than not. I was like, okay, we have these people... You've got an enemy. No, not even an enemy. I was just like, we have viewers. These people are passionately watching the show and we need every single person to watch. So there was actually one guy I reached out to. There was a guy who was tweeting vitriol at me on the daily, he was like, you know, you're a piece of trash
and you'll never make it, and if I ever meet you in the streets, and I DM'd this guy and I said to him, hey man, I just really want to understand, like why do you hate me so much? I've never met you, I've never said anything about you or your life, I'm just trying to understand this.
And I've never seen a faster switch of tone. He immediately was like, oh, hey, dude, oh, it's not personal and I have nothing against you. I just thought it was funny to pile on. And he said, in all honesty, I have nothing against you. I actually think you're quite funny, but I don't think you're going to succeed. I think the show will fail and you're going to crash and burn.
And then I said to him, OK, let's make a deal. If I'm still on the air in six months, you'll stay on as a lifelong viewer. And then if I'm gone, I will retweet your tweet and I'll say you were right. And he was like, oh, deal. And then he was like, good luck, man. I'm wishing you the best.
And then six months later, I DM'd him again. I was like, yo, are you still watching? And he's like, oh, the show's gotten so great. And you know what he made me realize? Crazy, that's gotten so great. And you know what he made me realize? Crazy, that's amazing. No, but you know what he made me realize? I'm honestly eternally grateful to him because he made me realize that most of,
not all of, but most of the, just most of the poisonous infighting that you have in America is due to the fact that most people are speaking past each other, not to each other and with each other. A hundred percent. People don't actually engage, people don't see each other as human beings, it's all a theoretical exercise.
But you'll be surprised to find that most people, when you sit down with them and actually, if you're forced to have a conversation where you connect, people start to see each other as humans that exist beyond their political affiliation. A lot of assumptions going on to yeah. Yeah, and it's just a game It's like it's like it's um. It's like sports fans I think American American politics has become like sports where you say everything to the opposing fans But you don't mean it mean it, but you go like this is the purpose of what we're doing
We're here to tell them that they need to die and we want to kill their players Yeah, we hate everything they do and the ref is biased when he rules in their favor. But when you meet in a grocery store, then they're humans because they're doing the same thing. They were basically exaggerating to make a point, you know? But yeah, when you get face to face with it, they get a little bit more real.
Yeah, I mean, I hate Manchester City as a football club. Wait, what? Yeah, I mean, I hate Manchester City as a football club. Wait, what? Yeah, I hate Man City. But then I also like, love, but I love Pep Guardiola, and I love Holland, and I love Kevin De Bruyne. Why would you hate, why would you hate, why would you hate all the players? I've never met anybody who has a, like a... Well, because I'm a Liverpool supporter, a massive Liverpool supporter.
I'm a Liverpool supporter, but I don't hate Manchester City. Well, just because they're going to beat us. Yeah, but I mean they've spent the money and it's like, I get annoyed but I... You see it's funny, that's where, like for me the rivalries are more games that I'll think of but Manchester City I find... My point was, I say I hate them but then I like all the players on the team. I like Pep Guardiola, I like Holland, I like De Bruyne, I like Phil Foda, and I like all their players, and so I don't really hate them,
but I have to because they're, I do hate the Boston Bruins, that's a hockey team, that I do. I do hate the Boston Bruins. Fucking send me your letters, I don't give a shit. Fuck you, I fucking hate them more than you fucking, like hate me. Trevor, now have you, have you since now become,
is following politics a hobby for you now? Do you enjoy it or now that you're out of there? Yeah, you don't need to be in the swamp anymore. So I don't follow politics as a hobby. What I try to do is understand which conversations can exist beyond the noise. You know, I often try and explain to people, when I'm having conversations with them, is... So, the most interesting thing about the US system for me is the fact that it leads people to believe that there are only two ways to do something.
You know, it's Republican and it's Democrat. And I've never understood that framing, to be honest with you. I've never even understood how newspapers will report. And these are like distinguished newspapers. They'll write a story that leads with Democrats win with, and it's a law that's changed. But I go, no, that should just be the law has changed and that should be how you report it.
It shouldn't be that it's a win for somebody or a loss for somebody else. It's a lot of the media. It's a lot of the media, how they frame everything. So I follow it now to try and understand where the issue lies and the politics ends. Because issues are real, politics are how we try and solve the issues.
But politics is not real, it's not actually a real thing. But Trevor, and I'm not being coy here at all, maybe this is... I think you've probably noticed in this country certainly, that there's not a lot of appreciation in any aspect of life for nuance in this country. Yeah, you're either on this team or that team. Yeah, and it's very binary, and it's always a sort of a zero-sum game.
That is part of the American experience. You win, you lose. There's no nuance. That is true, that is true. I will say, if you want to liken it back to sports, I always say to my American friends, I go, I see why soccer was never the most popular game and might never be.
It's because in soccer we have a draw. We sometimes say, you know what? Neither team won, neither team lost. This was a great game, everybody go home. It's winners and losers. And so if politics is also about winners and losers, then nobody wants to concede because it automatically means that they've lost. Which isn't a good way to have politics.
As opposed to compromise. Yeah, politics should never be about winning or losing. It should be about compromising and then, you know, understanding that the majority... It's even stranger. Do you ever think about it, when you look at America's results, I'm always shocked at how states are called blue or red, and then you look at the number, and it's like 51%, and people confidently say, well, that's a red state,
and I go like, but it's 49% blue. Right. Or vice versa. Everything's half and half, yeah. Right. Everything's right in the middle, yeah. Well, if you think, and this is true, I think, for politics in general,
and so I don't mean to come off as completely naive, but the idea that the actual politics are more important than the policy is absurd. All of the politics is supposed to be a mechanism by which we sort of, that sort of drives policy. And that it should be what people are concerned about, what the actual issues are, and they're not. They're much more invested in the game of it,
and as you said, the win or lose of the game. Yeah, but a lot of a lot of that I will blame you know to what you said Sean is like I think the media has to take a lot of blame for that because the media has enjoyed turning it into a game and the media has enjoyed turning it into a spectacle and so if they reinforce that narrative then I find lawmakers, you know one of the most interesting turning it into a spectacle. And so if they reinforce that narrative, then I find lawmakers... You know, one of the most interesting experiences I had when I first came to America was I went to New Hampshire
for the primaries. And this is literally, I've been in America for barely a year. Now I'm in New Hampshire, you know, and Vermont and all of these places. And I will never forget seeing, there were two politicians who were, you know, on the stump, and they were giving their speeches, and it was vitriolic, and they were, you know, this person's gonna destroy the country,
they're gonna do this, they, and then in the evening, I saw them at a diner, and the two of them were sitting together laughing, and they were like, how's your family? How's everything going? Since I was a kid, I don't understand that. Yeah, in many ways it's almost like wrestling. It's like American politics.
You see these people in the ring and it's like, Triple H, I'm gonna rip you limb from limb. And as a fan you're like, yeah, kill him, kill him. And then only to find out that like your favorite wrestler who hates the other wrestler in your mind is actually great friends and is the godfather to their child. I think American politicians don't do a they don't do the country service they do it a disservice by not showing everybody that they do get along that they go out together that they have
meals that they're friends they're in weddings. Also like I think language is important too like when you president, Republican or Democrat, says, who's ever in office, they say, well, the Democrats thought blah, blah, blah, or the Republicans thought blah, blah, blah. And it's like, you have to say the Republicans in Congress feel this way, or the Democrats in Congress. So what happens is it generalizes everybody,
well, I'm a Democrat, well, I'm a Republican. You know, now you're telling me that we all think that way? No, it's just the lawmakers think that way. You know what I mean? That's a good point. And also think about the idea that, look, it's the spring of an election year. Of course, and again, at risk of sounding completely naive,
of course they have to pit them against each other because they need to drive ratings because we know that all of it is driven by commerce. Everything in this country is driven by commerce. And so if there's no race, if there's no, they have to say so and so is leading by this. If the election were today, these are the weak spots. He's ahead, she's ahead. He's going to crush, he's not going to crush. They have to keep us in the game.
Yeah, they just have to be more discerning. Yeah, and they just have to be more discerning. Yeah, because they need us to watch the commercials in between. So if you really want to get mad at it, get mad at CNN and MSNBC and Fox and all of them, because they're just, all they're doing is in service of commerce. That's it. Yeah, yeah. It's completely in service of commerce. If I break it down into three levels, I'll go, you know, on the media side, I wish they would stop turning it into the spectacle that they do, but they probably won't, as you say, because the money is there.
Or that's what they want to get, you know, once you can make a profit and change everything. Sports get the best ratings in this country. So if they can turn it into a football game, they'll do it. But on the ground as well, I think as people, that's something that I found strange coming to America, is how people would say, I am a Democrat, I am a Republican. And I'd be like, what? What does that mean?
Where I come from, people just talk about how they voted, but they are not the thing. And I think if you take yourself away from being the thing, you allow yourself the opportunity to either be disappointed by the thing or step away from the thing when it is necessary. You know, because it shouldn't be a sport, you shouldn't be, like, I am a Liverpool supporter is correct, we will go up and down with Liverpool.
Whereas in politics you should just say, I voted for this and then I voted against it and it's like, I'm not that thing. Well imagine if you, imagine we lived in a world where you can just, all you did was you weren voting there were there was no such thing as a party and you just voted on issues. Yeah. Right. We'll be right back. Smartless listener, let me tell you about the Defender 110. For those who embrace the impossible, the Defender 110 is up for the adventure. This iconic vehicle has been redefined with thoroughly modern design.
The exterior offers compelling proportions while the interior has been built with robust materials and integrity. The Defender's capability is legendary. Whether you're facing off-road challenges or harsh weather conditions, you can rely on their innovative camera technologies to deliver unobstructed views and effortless maneuvering. Plus, their powerful innovations like the intuitive driver display and award-winning infotainment system make sure you stay connected. For me, it seems like the Defender 110 could be used in any state you live in under any weather condition. With weather getting worse and worse, the Defender 110 seems like it's the only car
that could handle anything. Ready for a wide range of adventures? The Defender family features the two-door Defender 90, the Defender 110, and the Defender 130, which seats up to eight. Learn more at LandRoverUSA.com forward slash Defender. SmartList is supported by GoodRx. Spring has sprung and so has allergy season. I know Scotty suffers tremendously from allergies during the spring. He's on all kinds of stuff. But when it comes to the cost of your allergy meds and other prescriptions, checking GoodRx can help you save and stay healthy. GoodRx is the free, fast, and easy way to find the prescriptions
you need at a lower price. With GoodRx you can instantly find discounts, compare prices, and save up to 80% at the pharmacy. GoodRx is accepted at all the major pharmacies in your neighborhood including CVS, Walgreens, Rite Aid, Vons, Walmart, Sam's Club, and many more. And remember GoodRx works whether you have insurance or not. Even if you have insurance, GoodRx may beat your co-pay price. So if you're looking for seasonal allergy relief with low cost prescription medications, GoodRx is a walk in the park for you this spring. For simple smart savings on your prescriptions, check GoodRx is a walk in the park for you this spring. For simple, smart savings on your prescriptions,
check GoodRx. Go to GoodRx.com slash SmartList. That's GoodRx.com slash SmartList. Thanks to Grammarly for their support. With so many emails and so much texting and so much everything going on in your life, it's nice to have something like Grammarly. It really, really works.
Sometimes one confusing email turns into 12 confused replies, right? And then a meeting to get aligned, and it's just a pain in the butt. Grammarly is a trusted AI writing partner that saves your company from miscommunication and all the wasted time and money that goes with it. I love that it kind of thinks for you. Grammarly's generative AI prompts help you kind of complete sentences before you even do.
And Grammarly helps you strike the right tone by suggesting a better word based on your audience and context. It's pretty futuristic, awesome stuff. When every word your team writes is clear, concise, and on-brand, everything gets better. Teams that communicate better with Grammarly report 66% less time spent editing marketing content and 70% improved brand compliance across the company. Join 70,000 teams who trust Grammarly to work faster, hit their goals, while keeping their data secure. Learn more at Grammarly.com.
Smart Lessons brought to you in part by Airbnb. I recently stayed at an Airbnb. I was on a golf trip. Can I tell you something? It was fantastic. It was easy and kind of felt like a little bit of a home away from home, you know, I went with my with my buddy JDog, that's all I'll say. It's not not JB. Anyway, maybe you stayed in an Airbnb before and thought to yourself This actually seems pretty doable. Maybe my place could be an Airbnb You already have an Airbnb
Airbnb and be it Maybe you're planning a getaway this summer and while you're away You could Airbnb your home and make some extra money to help pay for the trip. That's just math. Your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at airbnb.ca slash host. And now back to the show. Noah, so what about hosting?
Like do you still want to keep hosting? Is it something like you're like, I did it, I'm moving on to something else? On Airbnb? Oh no. Or like would you, like do you have aspirations to host the Oscars, the Emmy, like award shows or anything? Well, you've done, yeah, the Grammys.
How many years now? Right? Oh, that's right! I forgot. MTV and... The Grammys has been fun. I've done the Grammys a few times now. Now were you a huge music fan before that?
Have you, has your... You mean was I human? That's a strange question. Yeah, exactly. Well, who doesn't like music, Jason? No, but I mean like some people are obsessed with it. Jason doesn't know what humans do, dude. Well, maybe a better question would be, has your passion for music increased since you've
been behind the curtain? And by the way, I apologize. Of course I've watched it on the Grammys. I completely forgot. No, no, no, no. You know what? Can I... You've established your own right earlier in the show. Sorry, I didn't know you were a host of the Grammys. No, no, no, no. You know what, can I... You've established your own brand earlier in the Grammys. No, no, no, no. Don't do that to Sean, guys.
Don't do that. I know what he means. And I'll tell you why, Sean, it's funny. I don't think the Grammys is the same as like the Emmys or the Oscars or any of those shows because... Well, I'm an actor, so I watch those more. Yeah, but also the Grammys is like hosting a concert. You know, the Emmys and the Oscars and all these other awards, they do feel like an award show.
The Grammys just feels to me like a concert. Yeah, that's true, that's great. I've definitely developed a greater appreciation for artists. Seeing them rehearse, seeing how hard it is to get everything right, seeing them do it live, that's what's definitely increased. And then also my palettes, like every time I'm at the Grammys, I discover a new artist that I now become a fan of. What about a full genre?
Like, country, are you a fan of country now? I listen to way more country now than I ever did. You know what I mean? Everybody, like the Lou Combs, you name it. I just got into it because you would hear the song so many times in rehearsal and you'd see how amazing it could be, and then you fall in love with it. That Tracy Chapman performance.
Oh my god, I cried my eyes out. I know. I'm not a huge, a lot of the music at the Grammys is not really my taste generally. It's all kinds of music on the Grammys. But I'm such a like 90s indie rock fan. Oh, right. So they would have awarded your bands years ago. Yeah, if it was like Bill to Spill and Dinosaur Jr. and the Pixies, I would have been like,
ah, great. But then I watched that Tracy Chapman and you just forget what an unreal fucking talent she is. Yeah, Trevor, what is the phone number that you've gotten from hosting the Grammys all these years that you're most proud of? Which artist? What famous rocker do you now have on your phone? Oh, I don't have anybody's number, to be honest with you. You don't go,
Hey, hey, hey, it'd be great to hang out. I was in a band, you can have my number. I would gladly take your number. This is a strange thing to say, but like... So I always found it strange that people would try to be friends just because they're in a similar space. So I don't know how to explain it. You're famous, I'm famous, we should hang out.
Yeah, but okay, so this is what would happen to me. Alright, you would all probably understand this. I remember when I first came to America and now I would get invited to events But okay, so this is what would happen to me. Alright, you would all probably understand this. I remember when I first came to America and now I would get invited to events because you know, part of the Daily Show and you go to these events and everyone would be like, oh we should hang out. You take my number, take my... Oh my God, Trevor, we got to hang out sometime.
We got to get a coffee, we got to get a coffee. This guy's great. We got to get... Let me get your number. Where are you? Oh yeah, I'm there all the time. We got to do it. And I would give people my number and in my head I was like, wow, I'm making so many friends. These people are so friendly, this is amazing. And then I would hear nothing from them.
I would message them, I would hear nothing, they wouldn't respond at all. People, by the way, people in Hollywood change their numbers all the time. Like, I don't even know who, like, everyone has like a new number all the time. And then what would happen was, this was one of my favorite memories,
I met somebody, and this has happened a few times, I met the same person at another event, maybe like a year later, and they're like, oh my God, Trevor, this is, oh man, how have you been, congratulations, man, we gotta hang out, let me get your number, let me get, and I was like, I think you have my number, and they're like, no, no, no, no, I changed phones and I got a whole day.
Didn't your number... I was like, my number didn't change. And they're like, no. And I put my number in on their phone. And you know when you type it in on the screen, then my name just popped up. And I was like, you have my number. I'm like, wait, what? Yeah, yeah, yeah. And then what did Justin Theroux do? Oh, let me tell you, okay, I have the greatest And I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that.
I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that.
I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I can't remember yesterday, so chances are high. I was... So I was invited to a... It was a Netflix party before one of the Emmys. It was for like a whole bunch of nominees before the Emmys. And Ted Sarandos was hosting this event, and everyone's gathered. And it was... I mean, it was star-studded. It was crazy. And you don't see these people all the time.
That's the misconception everyone has, that if you're on the same platform, you just hang out. Right, you don't. I was just standing there, you know? And I look across the garden where this event's being held, and I see Jason, and I'm like, oh my God. And I've loved you forever. I go, you're easily one of my favorite comedy performers.
I mean, all of you are in different things. Like, Sean, I used to watch Will and Grace with my mom. It's okay. No, no, no. Don't throw the compliments away. I mean it, like literally. The timing, the cadence, the everything. Will, everything you do on like BoJack Horseman.
So I love comedy. I love the technique. But less, right, with Sean and Will? Yeah, I mean, I mean this honestly. You are easily one of my favorite funny people ever. But at that time, Ozark was just... It was my life. It was the best.
Anything I had seen that had flipped the whole genre of like, you know, drugs and everything. One of my favorite comedies too. Timing and... I thought it was very funny actually. So, I see you and you see me standing across the way. And you look at me and you just gave me like a little eyebrow like hello. And I was like oh damn, okay. And so I walked over to you and I said hello and you were very kind.
And I immediately went to you. I was effusive. I said I love everything you do and I went and I said you did this. I was likeusive, I said, I love everything you do and I just, I went and I said, you did this and I was like, I love game nights and I love this and I was just listing everything off because I love, I genuinely love them all. And, but then I said, I said to you, I said, oh and most recently you crushed it.
You know, I didn't think Ant-Man was going to be good and it was phenomenal. And you listened to me break down the whole Ant-Man everything. And then you paused. And I swear it was like you had written this. Your face, you went like, huh. And he said, do you think that I'm Paul Rudd?
And I will never forget that moment and I went, no, I thought that Paul Rudd was you. I gave him, but it's true, I gave him your performance, is how good I think you are. Anything good he did, I was like, it should be Jason Bateman, I guess. I strive to be Paul Rudd. And we just stared at each other awkwardly for a moment, and you said, huh, did you come here because you thought I was someone else?
And I said, no. But you said Ant-Man. And I said, I would rather say that I'm racist and you all look the same than admit that that happened. And then we just stood there awkwardly for a moment. And you were very nice. We just stood there and I said, well, one day we will meet again,
hopefully under different... And what I should have said is, don't worry, I'll never remember this because I know how to pour cement over bad memories. JB, do you remember that? I do not. He doesn't remember anything. By the way, don't take it personally. No, no, no, I'm glad. All I know how to do you remember that? I do not. He doesn't remember anything. Trevor, by the way, don't take it personally.
All I know how to do is remember dialogue that my brain at an early age was formed into that being a one trick, I'm a one trick pony. I can remember dialogue. What about a Coke dealer's number? Yeah, yeah, still, do you need some? Yeah, you remember that, yeah, you remember. It's been 20 some years.
Do you remember old dialogue though? No, I have a great delete button too, so that I have room on my drive for tomorrow's. To not remember the other things. Oh, he's one of the all-time great dialogue memorizers. But I will go, I'll go to a movie with somebody and two days later, I'll talk to that person, I'll go, oh, you know what I saw a couple days ago?
You got to see this movie. I've done it a dozen times. What does that mean? I do that too sometimes. I'll do it to Scotty. I'm like, I was at this movie, he's like, I was with you. I mean, it's terrible, but maybe it's good because I'm with somebody who feels so comfortable.
I mean, it blocks out the bad memories, right? Early onset? That could be. It could be just a trace. Why are you saying early? You think you're young? I'm not that young. Just let a fucking compliment into yourself? Here's another one, here's another one before you carry on. This was, can I just say, so you know obviously I'm a huge fan of the podcast and I understand the format. But here's the thing, I didn't know that the surprise guest was really a surprise thing.
Yeah. Okay. We didn't know you were going to come on. We've only broken it a couple of times. Yeah, so we were at the Vanity Fair Oscars party. Right. Yeah. And I saw you. And Will walks by, you walk straight to me, but you walk to me with the confidence of somebody
who knows that I'm coming on to the podcast. And you were like, hey! And then you said, yo, I'm so excited. I was like, oh! And I was like, I'm so excited to chat to you. And then as I said that, Jason was behind you, staring at me like I had killed his whole family.
He couldn't hear anything by the way, he was just staring at me and I said, I'm so excited to chat to you about Formula One. And then we started talking about Formula One. Interesting, it was funny that you said that now that I remember you saying that and I was thinking like, man he's really into Formula One, he's really honed in on me on the Formula One and he's been looking. I was panicking, I was like, oh D,'s really into Formula One. He's really honed in on me on the Formula One
and he's been looking... I was panicking. I was like, oh, I screwed the whole thing up. I screwed the whole thing up. And then I was like, oh, let's just get into Formula One. And you did look at me like, man, this guy really went deep into Formula One in the middle of an Oscars party. Right out of the gate. And then you walked away and then Jason came up to me
and he said, please, you didn't say anything. You don't fuck this up. You're the surprise guest. You don't fuck this up. I didn't say anything. I didn't say anything. You don't fuck this up. You're the surprise guest. You don't fuck this up. Fuck this up. I didn't say anything. I didn't say anything. And then he walked away.
Did you say that to him, JP? You said hi. Uh-huh. It's funny, I had somebody else at the thing as well. That same night after you, Trevor, I won't say it is, because I don't know whose guest it is, come up to me and it's somebody I've known a long time.
And I go, what's up, dude? And he goes, I'm coming to talk to you on your stupid podcast and I go well I didn't know that asshole sorry sorry sorry Rockwell did that too poor guy oh yeah Rockwell did you like getting gussied up like that traveling going out by the kind of events. By the way Trev, let me just tell you something. You looked really good on Sunday. I look cool like a guy. Very sharp. Thank you.
I've never heard that term gussied up. Gussied up. Yeah, we got some beauties here in this country. You ever been to Illinois? No. No, I've been everywhere actually. No, I do enjoy it. I went to, in South Africa, in school, you wear school uniform your whole life.
So I actually like dressing up like that because I feel like it's no stress. I go, yeah, you put on the pants, you put on the jacket, and you know you're doing it right. And then you have a good time. Women have it so tough. You gotta find the gown and then those shoes on. Yeah, I wear comfortable shoes. My toes are all individually spaced out. It's wonderful.
I think that when you said women have it so tough, they were expecting something a little more than the shoes and the gown, but OK. Well, in childbirth, I'm fucking with you. This is how we get into it. This is the entree. The stuff they've got to deal with. Trevor, I want to, you know, I brought it up
at the start of talking about Africa, and I want to know how often you get back to Africa. I'm so, I've never been. I've never been either. I want to go home. And I feel like I'm depriving myself. I really want to go. This is the same thing. This is the same thing I get in most of my hate mail.
When are you going back to Africa? Oh, geez. Oh, no. Well, let me just add to that. Can I go with you? I want to go because you're kind of like the dude. Do you get back often? I go back all the time. Yeah, I'm there all the time.
Especially since I left The Daily Show, I get to go back a lot more, you know, I spend time with my mom spend time with family I'm there I would say I'm there like every two two months to really That's great. Yeah, I love along the flight 16 hours from New York and then 20 It becomes like a weird 25 ish our journey from From LA. So yeah, 16 hours direct South African airways, right? Yeah, no, no, no, actually United's the only airline that flies there now.
Really? Yeah, so you know, life giveth and life taketh away. Yeah, and America, your new adopted home, do you generally, what's your take on it? Do you like it? Do you have favorite places? Oh, I love this place. So here's the thing, yeah, here's the thing about America,
is I think, again, you see, nuance is maybe what is lacking sometimes. I think people take for granted that you can live in a place where you find it both amazing and at many times disappointing, depending on what you're experiencing of it. You know, people sometimes walk up to me in the streets and they'll be like, you hate America, you piece of trash,
why don't you leave? And I'm like, who said I would not live anywhere I hate? Let's start with that. Secondly, I genuinely find a lot of America amazing. And I find it's the optimism that is etched into the very fabric of the country that I find amazing. You know, it's an amazing country where black people at a time when they had no rights believed that there was a path for them to get equal rights. Even that is a strange level of optimism that I think is beautiful and profound.
Yeah, considering how they were living, yes. Yeah, that's exactly my point. Yeah, it's incredibly ambitious and productive. It has that. And I think it's a wonderful trait to hold on to and to never lose. And so while America has many faults, other countries have many. I travel all the time, so I'm under no illusion. I don't think of America as best or worst.
I just think every place has the issues that it is dealing with at the time that it's dealing with them. So you, yeah, I know. There's something I've always loved about Americans and America as a place and how different each state and each city is, and I'm eternally grateful to be here. You're a West Coast guy or an East Coast guy?
I split it. I find the East Coast is great for your mind, the West Coast is great for your body. And I mean your body not physically, but just like, I feel like you breathe a little more, you sleep better, you eat better, it just has a calming effect on you, but the East Coast is great to get your brain just like really stimulated and going. Yeah, I agree with you. There's a lot in in I moved here when I was 20 from from Canada.
So it wasn't that far. But I do agree that there's so many great things. And I give this country a lot of shit. But I've been here a long time. And there's so many great things about this country. And I agree with you. But it's important for us to point out this stuff, you to be to be honest about the shortcomings because yeah and to care for it yeah well yeah you've got to think you've got to think of America like a Boeing
airplane you you should you should appreciate the fact that it can fly and the fact that it does is pretty amazing I mean the fact that this tin can is floating in the sky at 40,000 feet that's pretty amazing that's's wild. But if you stop paying attention to it and you don't try and constantly improve it, then the doors might fall off and the landing gears might fail. And the wheels fall off and it also inexplicably will lose power when it's traveling from Australia to New Zealand and fall 500 feet in a second.
The point is, I get what you're saying, but it's like sex too. It's like even when it's bad, it's still sex, right? Guys, are we saying that? Sure, yeah. Are we gonna go with that? I mean, is that the last thing we're gonna get Trevor to go sign? We could probably workshop that one a little bit after we're done. I'll need to digest that one.
Trevor, you are nine minutes over your obligated time, and I apologize for that. We love you. we thank you. What a fucking delight. What an absolute delight. Hey Trevor, let me get your number, let's hang out. We should do that. I'll let you know when I'm in. But actually, because you're a Liverpool fan and an F1 fan,
like we actually should hang out. I'll, you know, we can just watch the things, and then even if we say nothing, we had a good time. He's not a bad hand. We actually should, and I actually will do it. I actually will. I like that, thank you. Okay. All right.
Thank you, sir. Everybody went all right. Hopefully I see you again soon. Until then, thank you. Yeah, thank you so much for having me. God bless, maybe? This is really cool. Yeah, thank you, Trevor.
Nice to get to know you. We say, in Africa, we say, God bless, and may Simba always be by your side. Wow, that's exactly what I was thinking. Simba. I feel like he's kidding, but I'm gonna take him at his word. I'm gonna take him at his word.
Thank you, thank you. Thanks, Trev. See you in Joburg. Have a great rest of the day. Thanks, Trevor. Bye. Bye, buddy. Well, that, you know, listen, I'll tell you what,
our best guest at times. I really like that Trevor Noah. I really like him. Yeah, cool it, cool it. No, I know. You were spoken for and so is he all the way. No, I know. I think that he's a special dude.
I really like him. Yeah, he's very smart. Like, I didn't know anything about him. I just thought I was a fan. Apologize. What? Yeah, I apologize to him. But he a great vibe. Yeah, he's smart. Like I didn't know anything about him. I just thought I was a fan just from one. Apologize. Yeah, I apologize to him. But he's got, we didn't even, I love talking to him so much,
we didn't even get to his podcast on Spotify. His podcast on Spotify is called What Now, okay? What Now? What Now? What Now? And that's on Spotify. And he's on tour right now, like all over the world. And tickets are on sale through November.
So if you're in Singapore, Stockholm, Copenhagen, France, Germany, Rotterdam, Auckland, Melbourne, I mean, the guy is hopping all over. He's like a real international superstar. Yeah, yeah. Comedy superstar. The real yeah. Comedy superstar. The real deal. Most of the comedians that we know
who are our friends who we adore, but they're all going to fucking Denver and Omaha and shit, right, like a bunch of fucking ding-dongs, right? But then you got Trevor Ngoan, he's in Singapore. All our fucking stupid American comedian friends can suck it. Just, Trevor's out in the world, places, right? Sophisticated.
He's sophisticated. He's sophisticated, doing cool shit. Yeah, I like talking to people. I learn so much just from a quick hang like that. I've also been thinking about that city he performed at recently. Do you guys remember the name of that city? Oh, here comes, here comes, here comes.
Are you trying to wrap it up already? We've barely talked about him. What do you want to say, Moore? I love him. He's super smart. I want him to come back so I can learn more. He's excited about his bye. Let him get to it. What were you talking about, Sean? Well, it's a place where a lot of rich people live.
Where's that? Dubai! God, he's had that loaded for a half hour. Smart. Do-fi! God, he's had that loaded for a half hour. Do-fi! Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarff. If you like Smartless, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at wondery.com slash survey. Scammers are best known for living the high life until they're forced to trade it all in for handcuffs and an orange jumpsuit once they're finally caught.
I'm Saatchi Cole. And I'm Sarah Hagge. And we're the host of Scamfluencers, a weekly podcast from Wondery that takes you along the twists and turns of some of the most infamous scams of all time, the impact on victims, and what's left once a facade falls away. We've covered stories like a Shark Tank certified entrepreneur who left the show with an investment, but soon faced mounting bills, an active lawsuit filed by Larry King, and no real product to push. He then began to prey on
vulnerable women instead, selling the idea of a future together while stealing from them behind their backs. To the infamous scams of Real Housewives stars like Teresa Giudice, what should have proven to be a major downfall only seemed to solidify her place in the Real Housewives Hall of Fame.
Follow Scamfluencers on the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to Scamfluencers early and ad free right now on Wondry+. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.